I think people have the misconception
that the Big Bang is universe starting
from a point in fact it's very different
from that it probably you know that you
the universe is expanding but so if we
go backwards in time then you can watch
the universe contract as you go
backwards in time so for example if you
took a tabletop then any two points
would be get closer together but the
points that are way far apart if you had
let's say it's an infinite tabletop so
as these points get closer and closer
together you still have a tabletop
that's infinite in extent it's not like
everything comes into one point but
eventually you reach such a high density
things are so compact and sand right on
top of each other that we lose our
description physics fails that's what
the Big Bang is so it's actually we
would need to have a theory of quantum
mechanics and gravity simultaneously to
be able to discuss physics going
backwards in time any further so it's
really a high density situation that we
call a Big Bang but there's really no
explosion there's no bang there's no
single singular point but so yes it does
make sense to ask well what happens when
you reach that density and that's what
people are trying to do in in theories
of quantum gravity such as string theory
or well some of the cosmology that I've
done also is in the context of of brains
where our observable universe is living
on a three-dimensional surface in a
higher dimensional universe and there
could be other brains out there and how
these brains intersect one another and
they're their emotions and so on has
been has been so there are different
avenues to try to push it push back our
level of knowledge and they're very
active but very difficult everything was
more dense and then there's a certain
point where which we which we call the
Big Bang and it's from that point
forward that we we start our clocks so
that's and then so when we say the
universe is 13.7 billion years old is
relative to that
very high density situation